grass is what we were doing at the end
of last term so it's been a little while
since we um had this in our heads so
let's get our head back in the space do
you remember
i gave you a metaphor
for what graphs are i said um you know
there's equations these equations
equations like this
y equals x and that's going to be our
first one okay is equations and graphs
are kind of like well does anyone
remember what the metaphor the analogy
was
anyway
clearly it was a very effective metaphor
um
the metaphor was musical okay the idea
is you can take sheet music
okay which has all these weird marks and
scratches and those kinds of things and
what they signify you can turn this into
something audible namely music
this is the same idea
you have something marks symbolic it
represents something which you don't
make audible like music you make it
visual visible light graphs okay so
they're pictures it's just about drawing
pictures so does anyone remember what
does y equals x what does it look like
yeah good straight line let's draw it in
do you use a ruler if you've got one
there
there you go okay so
these are called this is a straight line
so it's called a linear graph right a
linear graph
and we learned about all kinds of linear
graphs there's lots of different ones
not just y equals x yep
yes yes yes yes um math is math is like
that it keeps on building on the same
ideas okay but then it goes further
every time you go you get older
they take these same ideas and then they
push a little more and then the next
year they push a little more
ah okay we'll get to that in a second
okay before we get on to parabolas let's
just think about the different kinds of
linear graphs that there are because y
equals x is not the only one can someone
give me an example one that would look
different to that yeah the other way
which way negative negative negative
okay good so instead of y equals x
i'll label this one y equals x okay
what would i have to do
well x equals y and y equals x
are really actually the same thing
yeah right it's a bit like okay if you
got a c saw right and then it's like
you've got one thing on one side and the
same thing on the other and then you
swap their places
it's still the same arrangement isn't it
right they're still going to go up and
down in exactly the same way to make it
go in the other direction what do you
have to do
okay so let's let's draw it in okay
by the way just as a point of curiosity
i wonder if you can think about why this
might be the case
you'll know
why you'll know that you've drawn
accurately if there should be a right
angle these lines
y equals x and y equals minus x they
should meet at 90 degrees if they're not
your scale will be a bit off and the one
of the questions is why is that
good
yeah yeah well i've seen your circles
before that doesn't surprise me
all right good that was another example
can someone give me another one how else
can we change yet
yeah we will get to that i'll uh i'll
draw one let's just label this
preemptively we'll get there in a second
can anyone give me a different linear
graph yeah
would one be like just like a straight
line okay so these are all straight
lines but the way you did your hand i
think you mean a horizontal horizontal
line okay so let's draw a horizontal
line in like say this one
on the same graph yeah all same graph
that's why i remember i asked you to
draw this one a bit bigger so we can fit
a few on there why is that on the actual
zero line uh okay so i've got a i could
put in a whole bunch of different
horizontal lines couldn't i um i've
deliberately put this one not on the
axis so that i can see where it is
yes it would it would it would so
this this line here right the graph it
has an equation wouldn't it depend on
what you're trying to find
it does it does right now we're kind of
just making up stuff right so
we could we can let this equal a few
different things right now you've got
this equation y equals x this equation y
equals minus x right
now this equation here horizontal lines
will have a equation like this i'll just
give you an example y equals one let's
just label that for now okay
which means that well it depends on your
scale doesn't it right so if i say i'm
gonna call that point one
if i call all of these points one right
their y value you'll get one okay good
so you know who said y equals one yep
doesn't x normally just equal one
if i have x equals one i'll get
something else i still get straight
like what i mean is it says y equals x
right yep isn't x only one or is that oh
wait no sorry that's normally
just used it's like as a test like you
just i'm just going to try a value and
see what happens okay good
does it say it again y
instead of y equals one if i change that
number i'm gonna go like y equals
negative one will be down here x equals
one and x equals minus one okay yeah
let's do it let's do x equals one if
this is y equals one and it's horizontal
what would you expect x equals one to
look like
yeah good vertical fantastic so let's
let's do it
okay now if we've chosen the same number
namely one they're both going to
intersect here
okay now my question to you is
what are the coordinates of that point
what's its x value
and what's its
y value and the answer is look they're
both one right one one
okay
all right
so what have we done we've gone x equals
y x equals
sorry y equals x y equals negative x
you've shown me some horizontal vertical
lines okay
i'll try one more and then i think at
that point is this thing is too crowded
okay um we have some gradients of these
lines right they all have different
gradients let's think about each one
okay we'll start with the simplest one
the first one y equals x um gradient
about slope right it's like is it steep
or is it shallow what's it doing okay so
what's the gradient of that first line y
equals x
so gradient is rise over run isn't it
okay so it would mean for instance if i
if i rise one unit
i run one unit as well right so rise
over one would be one
over one which is one okay oh and you
could say what if i go across two units
if i go across two i'm gonna go up two
right so then rise over one would be two
over two which is still one okay good so
for this line down here and if you have
another color it'll be really useful
because it's going to start getting a
bit muddled right
um i'm going to say the gradient what's
our usual letter for gradient
g stands for gradient but it usually
means gravity actually so they use m so
i'm going to say m equals one okay
so far so good
the second line we drew was going down
right so what does that mean about
gradient
it's negative it's negative it's it's
not it's not rising it's it's dropping
okay so m is going to be negative one
one good one
okay
now
careful this is a bit different the next
line we do is horizontal
now
look at that horizontal line how far is
it rising one
zero
one
how do you do that now you look at it
right you're like as i'm as i'm going
across the line am i going up or down
and the answer is i'm not going up or
down i thought it meant this
already all right okay well i'm thinking
about how it changes how it changes okay
so as luke has said and does as well um
it is not rising and it's not dropping
so therefore it's it's rising zero oh
that's what i meant before yeah that's
what you were thinking of so therefore
this line here m is equal to zero right
all right one last one
the vertical line the vertical line
hmm
is it
is it rising
well
kind of depends on your point of view
doesn't it like where do you start if
you start here well it's rising
but if you start here
it it's dropping so that's a bit
confusing maybe we should ask another
question
where is it running that's that's a
horizontal thing how far does it run
well i think it runs i think this
vertical line does horizontally right
the same thing that this line does
vertically
answer it's not going to the left and
it's not going to the right
so the run is zero right
hold on
gradient equals rise over run
and you just told me we just worked out
run is zero in this case
rise
over
zero zero
what happens when you divide by zero
you can test that what what does your
calculator tell you calculators don't
know everything but sometimes they're
handy they can give you useful
information
what does your calculator tell you
it tells you math error some some
calculators will tell you
undefined and that's actually what we
write m is
undefined
this vertical line it doesn't have a
gradient because it's not running
anywhere so you can't do rise over brush
so wait do you just say rise over 0 or
just zero um i would say i wouldn't say
either of those i'd say when i get to
this point
i would say you can't divide by zero
dividing by zero breaks things i can
explain why later on if you like
it doesn't work you can't divide numbers
by zero and get a meaningful result out
the end so you say it's undefined it
doesn't have a gradient that's a bit
weird okay but it's true
so there you go four lines four
gradients any questions
great let's move on and this is going to
be a bit quicker okay um
a few of you said to me parabolas that's
why equals x squared do you remember
what the shape is like can you trace it
out with your hands yeah good you've got
that kind of shape like that um this
looks like a smiley face like this
it doesn't have to be a smiley face
right
it might be
it might be upside down how would i make
it upside down by making it negative
good just like this one
just like this one
it's cool so so again you can have this
right that would be negative x squared
and then there were all kinds of
variations on that right we could make
it
steeper
right
you can move it side to side as well
right you could move it over here
you get the idea same shape okay
so that was our parabola y equals x
squared linear graph
a parabolic graph
following on the from the parabola okay
you then ask me two
side questions which weren't
part of the course but they were really
interesting we looked at what happened
when you changed that number up there
to a three do you remember what it was
like
it was it was like it was like a it
starts like a problem
yeah yeah oh good okay so instead of
coming back up
it drops it drops off like that
so this is this is a cubic function that
shape doesn't actually have a particular
name apart from it's a cubic function
there was one other one you asked me
which is that here's y equals x squared
what happens if you swap the letters
right what happens if you do x equals y
squared do you remember yeah
yeah it's sideways that's right so
here's what you do right
see how you swapped the letters right
let's just do this really quickly
because i explained it but before but
it's been a while
so i swapped the letters here so i'm
going to swap the letters
here as well can you do that well i'm
just as a
as a picture for what we're doing okay
now if you swap them right now we have
to look at it sideways because we're
used to this being our vertical thing
yeah right so you look at it sideways
and you draw your parabola like this
okay
now that's the shape you get and then
you can put your x's and y's back where
they belong
okay
now i'm not going to dwell on that for a
whole time because that's it's just a
side note but like it's literally a side
note but it's just interesting okay yeah
um what does it say in the parabola
um yeah so so these are
equals
yeah that what does that say yeah yeah y
equals x squared okay sorry there's a
few graphs on top of that
making you look like it's 12. okay
notice that's right yep
but yeah yeah like what if it's y equals
to negative
y squared would that be the other way
you mean this
that does that be the other one well
what happened here
it went
it reflected it flipped so when you do
this which doesn't go down on that
left the opposite it reflects
it reflects that